Good morning, Hank. It's Friday, December
3rd. As you can possibly tell by the lamp
shaped like a jellyfish, I'm not in my house.
Instead, Hank, I'm in Miami with its beautiful
beaches and its palm trees and its fancy art
fairs, none of which I get to enjoy! Because
even though I mentioned earlier that it is
December 3rd, I still haven't finished NAFADOYBIMSCOM,
NAtional Finish A Draft Of Your Book I Mean
Seriously Come On Month! It's like it's still
November! Ahhhhh! I'm a giant squid of anger!
Well, Hank I've got to put aside the giant
squid of anger in my heart because today we
have to talk about giant squids of love. But
even more importantly, I want to discuss with
you why I am so fascinated by the sex lives
of species different from us.
Okay, Hank, so here is the giant squid: Majestic,
very secretive. We don't know what they eat.
We don't know how deep they're able to dive.
We don't know what they do for fun. And we
don't really know for sure how they mate.
But we've got some ideas, and they involve
penile fire-hoses. Alright, Hank, so most
squid have eight arms; two longer tentacles
that they use for feeding; and one hectocotylus,
which is kind of like a penis except it falls
off every time they have sex. Like, they put
it into the girl squid, and then the girl
squid kind of breaks it off. Giant squids
don't have a hectocotylus, instead they have
a three-foot-long penis, and like a lot of
invertebrates they produce spermatophores,
which are like these sacks that contain sperm.
But, unfortunately, female giant squid anatomy
doesn't really give you a convenient place
to put that spermatophore, and that's where
the fire-hose comes in.
Hank, in the last 48 hours I've read so much
about giant squid sex that I'm surprised the
hotel still lets me have internet. And so,
I can tell you that without fail researchers
who are hypothesizing about giant squid sex
always refer to the male squid penis as a
fire-hose. Because what they think happens
is the male squid's penis approaches a female
squid's arm and then, like a fire-hose, shoots
a spermatophore into the arm. At which point,
the female, as you can imagine, is like "Oh!
What did you just do to me!" Which is actually
bad for the males because the females are
much larger, and that, biologists think, is
why the male squid penis is so long: so they
don't have to get too close to the females
in order to inseminate them.
Now, Hank, I'm not an expert in the field,
but it seems to me that fire-hosing your spermatophore
into a lady arm is not a pleasant or even
very efficient method of reproduction. And
it makes me wonder: Why? Why don't they just
find a better way to do it? But from an evolutionary
perspective, is it ultimately more helpful
to have an efficient mating system, or is
it more helpful to have, say, an eye that's
a foot freakin' wide, which is what giant
squids have. In fact, we see examples over
and over in our world - we've been talking
about them all week - of incredibly inefficient
mating. Hank, its almost as if sex is not
actually the most important thing that animals,
including humans, do. And Hank, I believe
that is one thing giant squids are trying
to tell us. I've got to go back to my story,
but Hank I will see you on Monday.
Ah! Nerdfighters, I almost forgot, but because
you proved that space pasta is far less efficient
than Earth beef, you now get to challenge
us to do something difficult and/or horrible.
I should add, however, that a nerfighter named
Stanage did some research suggesting that
space pasta might actually be more efficient
than Earth beef if we use the space shuttle
to pick it up instead of Apollo 11, provided
that there was already space pasta on the
moon. But sadly, at least as far as we know,
there isn't space pasta on the moon. At any
rate, you figured it out so you get to challenge
us. Leave you suggestions for challenges in
the comments and upvote you favorites and
as always: DFTBA.